we are around 100 meter from the border
so in five minutes he'll be in say
inshallah so I'm just waiting the sign
from the the smuggler and when he tell
us okay yeah lockers so we we run like
so fast my name is Ahmed deep I am a
freelance journalist they call me the
son of war
[Music]
I became photographer the first time my
uncle brought me a small camera at the
beginning I was filming nature at the
sea in Gaza tip by step I tried to teach
myself and to learn by myself in 2008
the first war in Gaza I was working in
hospitals and following the bombs and
the massacres I was very worried faced
my friends or my family in any moment I
was thinking of call that okay my family
with danger
[Music]
an Israeli warplane they bombed the
house of my uncle's so they killed 11
members of my family my uncles and their
sons and daughters and children as well
it was horrible but the death of my
family gave me a vision to be
photojournalist
[Music]
each time I go to to cover the conflict
I faced a lot of
be sober and watch Brock Europe
[Music]
one time I was there and they told me
they bombed a place and the old city of
Aleppo so we went there and the first
thing I saw it's an old man he was under
terrible his face it was covered by dust
and by blood I didn't imagine that he
will be alive then I realized that he
still Payton I can feel I will die in
any minute because of the bomb Bank I
have you firing I go to the front lines
I feel there are a lot of similarities
between Gaza situation and Syrian
situation most of the majority of the
people there are refugees in Gaza
my family they are refugees
I can feel the suffering of the people
who are fu G as well I feel like the
same as I see in Gaza there are the same
eyes who are in Syria
[Music]
the agency they are not being well they
are dealing with me as I am photographer
or as the local journalist not like
international journalist I feel that
there's less respect for the Arab
journalists but we are the one who is
suffering my family my friends they are
suffering because we are from the same
country or at least we are from the eye
of the community if there is anything
happened I am the one who will witness
maybe one day I will be the news itself
one time I gave up and I said it's okay
it's the last minute of my life
[Music]
you know she avoided a memorably this
was in Aleppo the fighters they talked
me there there was sniper but we didn't
notice he started shooting toward us
[Music]
simultaneous machine I'm an animal
honestly I never like told my family
that I am filming in Syria like I don't
want them to be very worried about me
a fellow samovar
[Music]
I want to send message to the world that
this still life in Gaza and Egypt in sea
and all conflict zones in Syria right
now when I go there like I can't feel
the people they are like kidding and a
lot of life you can feel it in Aleppo so
it's not a very sheen I am in touch with
them all the time even if I'm not in
Syria we live together we sleep together
we had good memories together we have
been in the front lines together the
fighters they were carrying their
weapons and I was carrying my ribbon
which is the camera
[Music]